the ministers today had very fruitful I
believe exchange on all the different
topics on the agenda it was a good
exchange very frank very open very
constructive on which I believe we agree
on the fact that common ground was there
on I would say 90 95 percent of issues
we also discussed something else that I
believe it's extremely important which
is the opportunities for us to
strengthen cooperation in other issues
that are not crisis related being it
economic cooperation trades investments
opportunities for young people education
all the work that we can do and we are
already doing but we can strengthen
across the Mediterranean and far beyond
that to make sure that our people enjoy
better conditions of life we believe
that the meeting that we had today here
in Brussels was indeed one of the
meetings that we would reckon on by way
of inspiring from it the will to
continue and the strength required to
see to it that our meeting in Sharm
el-sheikh succeeds
Robitaille era an elect America's here
men
Baphomet yep a lockable mysoline a
lagina say Ocala funa be tomorrow alma
da Gama Manila and Abhishek LaMotta
rousillon Allah premature me chef Lata
Wasel illa de Ferran Mac tube few Waseca
toss Doran has elected my own a man
toast Iran has elect me attack is cool
it off a home at what cool and he Gabby
yet and let you out - akashi room unless
you cannot be take it again